the Democrat mayor of New York Eric  Adams has you got to give credit where  credit's due done something that  actually will likely improve the city if  severe mental illness is causing someone  to be unsheltered and a danger to  themselves we have a moral obligation to  help them get the treatment and care  they need we can no longer deny the  reality that untreated psychosis can be  a cruel and all-consuming condition that  often requires involuntary intervention  supervise medical treatment and  long-term care this is the right policy  it could go terribly wrong there are  lots of Hazards here but this is the  right policy it is not compassionate or  just or conservative to allow crazy  people to die in the street especially  in cities that get very cold in the  winter